hello and merry christmas
my name is larry arn i work at hillsdale
college
and this is the most important being on
earth her name is charlotte or we call
her the squink and she is our first
grandchild
she seems a good thing to have around
here
in a christmas message because
the christmas message is about a baby
and every baby represents something like
christmas because
babies are small
and yet everyone knows they're of
infinite value certainly this one is
yes
not true
uh think about the nativity story
did you have to memorize bible passages
when you were young i did and
look at that the star has fallen
and
i had to memorize the luke account of
the nativity
and i can remember most of it and there
were in the same country shepherds
dividing in the field watching their
flocks by night
and the angel lord came upon them in the
glory of the lord shone about them
and this is the part i like and they
were sore afraid
so what were they afraid about and what
did the angel come to say
this baby had been born
and the news of the baby
was so shocking
that
herod
killed
many babies to make sure he got that one
killed
because that one was going to challenge
his rule
well that one did challenge his rule
and the rule of every tyrant in history
because the christmas message is
nobody except god can have absolute
power and nobody but god
deserves
it a very turbulent world right now
our college is thriving
i think that's because of help from
people like you
but i think that's because we together
we remember
that there are eternal things
and one of the finest
happened at christmas when a baby was
born
thank you and merry christmas
[Music]
you